sur les rives de la mer noire la menace
est dans toutes les têtes
odessa la perle du sud de l'ukraine
pourrait voir les russes attaqués par la
mer cet habitant viens ici tous les
jours nourrir les mouettes et en ce
moment il a les yeux rivés sur l'horizon
on sait que les navires us ne sont pas
loin hier je nourrissais les mouettes et
ils ont lancé cinq missiles
mais on n'a pas peur
sur ces images tournées par la marine
ukrainienne on voit l'un de ses navires
russes faire feu vers les côtes ils ont
tiré un autre missile
une présence au large qui fait craindre
un débarquement sur cette plage longue
et étroite propice à l'accostage est
filmée ici quelques mois avant la guerre
l'armée ukrainienne a placé des mines ce
véhicule blindé creuse un sillon pour y
placer des engins explosifs
les abords de la plage sont aujourd'hui
sous haute surveillance
impossible de s'approcher et
interdiction de filmer non stop toute la
plage est désormais sous le contrôle de
l'armée
sur cet autre plage pas de mine mais des
habitants qui remplissent des sacs de
sable pour en faire des barricades pour
le centre ville ici personne ne craint
d'invasion le bord de mer seraient
protégés par une digue sous-marine
les navires russes ne peuvent pas
débarquer leurs troupes ici parce qu'il
fracasserait la coque de leur bateau
juste là
[Musique]